[Music]
e
hey everyone I'm Justine and I just want
to welcome you to our celebration of
world bromosa day this is the 10th
anniversary and this is something that I
never thought that I would be
celebrating or be a part of or that I
even had any idea even existed a few
years ago until I unfortunately did get
a blood clot and it was surprising and
it was shocking you know because it's
not something that you would think that
someone young and healthy gets but it's
pretty wild how this does affect so many
people but I'm so excited to be joined
with three incredible guests today we
have Jean Connors hi Jean hi Justine I'm
so excited to see you again so do you
want to give everyone a quick little
intro and why you're here today so I'm
um a member of the world thrombos St
steering committee um and we do a lot of
work to bring public awareness to the
existence of blood plots and Venus
thrumbo embolism I'm a a coagulation
hematologist I'm a physician in Boston
at Brigman Women's Hospital uh and Dana
Farber Cancer Institute and I take care
of patients who've had blood clots or we
want to even try to prevent blood clots
in some people so thank you for having
me thank you so much now Kelsey you I
think you're a six-time blood clot
Survivor I don't want to get your
numbers wrong here but you have been
through a lot so do you want to share
quickly about why you're here sure hi
everyone it's so great to be here my
name is Kelsey um six it's actually
seven as of July of this year so that
number has increased a little bit but
I'm here to speak on this panel because
I found world thrombos to stay about two
or three years after I suffered my first
and second blood clot and since they
have given me the opportunity to speak
to others in situations and
opportunities like this and it's amazing
to get the story out there to network
I've met amazing people who have had the
same experience and it's just something
where you can broaden your community but
also create a Awareness on something so
important and near dear to my heart it's
awesome well thank you and I'm so sorry
that we had to add another one to that
but I'm so glad that you're here to
share your story and next up we have
Gabby you are one of the most popular
Instagram stars in Brazil now let's talk
briefly about why you're here and your
clot story hi guys so I'm Gabby I'm from
Brazil and I'm super excited to be here
talking about this cuz I never really
have a chance to talk about my
experience it was just once but um I
know the the importance of this subject
and I don't see as many people talking
about this you know and I'm I'm happy to
be here I'm so excited to be talking to
you guys thank you so much so now this
is in celebration of world thrombosis
day and this is the 10th anniversary and
this entire campaign and the entire
reason behind this is to really raise
awareness about blood clots now this
whole Global campaign Tak takes place
and this is really it's kind of a
critical thing that I feel like a lot of
people don't understand one in four
people globally die from conditions
related to blood clots and what's
incredible about this campaign is really
bringing people together to kind of
share their stories now before we get
into more in depth about ladies your
stories I would love to hear more from
Jean about what exactly is a blood clot
and just some more medical terms that
that we may not completely understand
well thanks Justine and and I'm
delighted to be here with everybody and
I'm sorry you've all experienced blood
clots um I'm going to start very simply
blood clot is like you know if you cut
your skin and it stops bleeding it stops
bleeding because of a clot but the big
BL blood vessels inside your body the
veins move more slowly than the arteries
and they can get blood clots inside them
whenever there are a number of different
types of f of factors that can provoke a
blood clot such as trauma such as low
flow or slow flow through the veins such
as if you're sitting in one position for
a long time such as like a sixh hour or
a 15-hour plane flight um or if you have
other factors that increase the
stickiness of the blood is the easiest
way to say it we call it a
hypercoagulable state or a prothrombotic
state but many different factors can
affect how easy it is or how hard it is
for the blood to clot and so some of the
factors particularly women um experience
increased risks with estrogen
progesterone containing oral
contraceptives during pregnancy actually
women um have the highest risk of having
thrombosis during um say 20 to 50 years
because of pregnancy so they have a
higher risk than men during that age
period because pregnancy is a risk for
getting blood clots but there are many
many other risks for getting blood clots
some people inherit risks for blood
clots infections inflammation I could go
on and on but I won't but but that's
really when we get a deep vein
thrombosis because of um particularly
not moving that's usually in the legs
although Justine can tell us about her
experience with the deep vein thrombosis
in the arm and then some people get
pulmonary embolis which is actually
blood clots in the lungs and these can
be clots that move from the veins and
the legs uh through the right side of
the heart to the lungs and they get
trapped in the lungs um or they can
sometimes form in the lungs directly so
lots of different ways to get blood
clots the the one thing I do want to add
to something that Justine mentioned
though is that many people don't expect
young people to get blood clots and so
often when people show up at the
emergency room it's not the first thing
that emergency room doctors think of
when someone's in their 20s or 30s or or
even their
40s yeah and it's interesting too and
just I guess briefly my story for anyone
who's joining who hasn't heard about it
I do have a full YouTube video kind of
chronicling this whole thing is mine was
kind of interesting because it came from
more of an anatomical and it was because
the blood flow was not able to get
through my first rib and with that it
then also did turn into a pulmonary
embolism and I think one of the things
that's really important I think for a
lot of people women especially younger
people who are experiencing these types
of things is to advocate for your health
you know I went to the ER and definitely
probably should have went a little bit
sooner but I kept thinking no this can't
be this can't be a blood clot and
thankfully you know my family and like
my mom more specifically she had always
like taught us about blood clots because
it did run in the family so that was
always in the back of my mind so knowing
and going into the doctors when
obviously my arm was like triple the
size and it was like purple they clearly
something was wrong but I was very
adamant about I think this is a blood
clot and then you know getting that
diagnosis and having them say well
you're going to need to get your first
rib removed if you continue doing these
specific activities because I used to do
a lot of Sword training and lightsaber
training which was the craziest thing is
that is now in my medical history of
like being basically being a Jedi is the
reason that I got this blood from the
excessive uh repetitive motions like
that but that's never something that you
would ever think so you know if you ever
do see those signs to anybody watching
don't be afraid to go ask for help get
to the doctors go to the ER because
they're more medically equipped to be
able to to take care of those things now
I think it's also interesting because I
feel like all three of us have very
different stories um Kelsey I would love
to hear from you because you you've
definitely got the clot record here so I
guess
congratulations um and I'm just so so
honored and happy that you're still here
to be able to to tell us about it so for
you I mean what were your symptoms and
and and kind of just go through that
story for us sure so none of my symptoms
were really textbook um which made it
each time very difficult to recognize
that I was having a blood clot but I
will say the first blood clot that I had
was the portal vein thrombosis in my
liver and my biggest symptom was my
belly was very distended um it looked as
if I was seven or eight months pregnant
um almost overnight I would say within
like 72 hours time and it's I laugh
about it now because it was around New
Year's Eve and I was drinking champagne
with my friends and I literally I just
thought I was bloated from drinking
champagne so when I went to work one of
the Physicians that I worked with looked
at me and was like are you okay Kelsey
and I was like yeah why and she you know
not being rude she's like um you know
like your belly is really big like you
don't look like you are feeling that
well I think you should go to the
emergency room and I was like Dr K I
have a meeting in 15 minutes like I'm
not going to the emergency room and she
insisted that I went and that day I
didn't leave the emergency room for
about two weeks so that was my first um
experience in diagnosis with the symptom
but therefore once I had my pulmonary
embolism I drove myself to the ER I
actually had very very very bad anxiety
type feelings and my heart was beating
out of my chest when I went to sit down
it felt like a stabbing pain in my chest
and I I just thought it was abnormal so
I went to the ER and they said to me you
have a blood clot and I said I know it's
in my belly it's not done dissolving my
body hasn't absorbed it and they're like
no actually you have a pulmonary
embolism so all of that to say um I
didn't have your typical textbook
symptoms but I knew what I was
experiencing in my own body was not
normal and looking back I wish I would
have recognized it days earlier and
taking action days earlier as you had
mentioned you should have probably gone
to the emergency room sooner but um I
have definitely learned um as I've
gotten older and I will say my last
blood clot that was in my hand it was in
a super superficial vein I looked down
at my hand and I noticed I had about a
golf siiz a golf ball siiz lump on the
top of my hand and it was black and blue
and very very hard to move my hand and
at that point I immediately went to the
emergency room and was sick Ed with a
blood clot and this whole time you've
been on blood thinners as well too yes
so I was on blood thinners I've been on
various types of blood thinners and
unfortunately I have had a blood clot on
three different types of blood thinners
wow I mean Jean what do you have to add
to that because that does seem like it's
you know the blood thinners are supposed
to be like our Saving Grace yeah no
again I think this is a very dramatic
story and and you know I think both of
you had unusual presentations right we
think deep vein thrombosis and you've
got swelling in your leg and it hurts
and now we have someone who has a
swollen arm um again from compression I
have to throw in we celebrate World
thrombosis day on October 13th because
verow postulated this triangle these
three different components that combine
to form a blood clot and one of them is
compression so that's what you had
Justine with your rib compressing the
veins coming out of your arm um but
Kelsey you know it's it's surprising how
many people actually have new clots or
extension of old clots despite starting
anti-coagulation and in the first two
weeks after someone's on
anti-coagulation we kind of accept a low
rate of of new events so you know one of
the I mean I don't want to get all
doctory here and say well what how long
were you been on it and were you taking
it and did you miss a dose and were you
taking any like antibiotics that might
of interfered with its activity but
there's a lot of factors that go into um
making sure that the anti-coagulation is
adequate even if you've done quote
everything right and I'm I'm sure you
know people do everything right to the
best that they can they sometimes are
not effective enough because that
stickiness of the blood the
hypercoagulability is just strong and
then we have to do some other things
like change the medication type or
change the dose or look at interfering
factors that might make the
anti-coagulant not as effective uh in
you at any given
time yeah no thank you and then someone
also I saw mentioned in the the comments
that they are saying wait because you
you mentioned compression they said
should we not wear compression socks
when we fly so that's a different type
of compression we actually do want that
type of compression to keep the blood
flow yeah know and I again so
compression is when we talk about
causing a blood clot is you know if you
think of your um veins coming out of
your legs for example as like you know
those paper drinking straws that if you
get them wet they kind of get collapsed
they're not like those plastic ones
which are kind of like the arteries so
if you have a plastic drinking straw
that's your artery but the pla the paper
ones that get smooshy and stuck together
those are like veins and so um if you
have something pushing on that it's very
hard the pressure is hard in for the the
vein to push the blood past something
outside of the brain the vein pressing
on it um compression stockings are a
different story though because when you
stand up or when you're sitting in one
position you make it harder for the
blood to get back to your heart because
gravity is pulling the blood down into
your legs or if you're sitting in one
position for a long time you're sort of
kinking off the veins you know at that
right angle where your legs join your
body compression stockings put pressure
against the veins in a good way to help
the blood flowing back up to the heart
so yes to compression stockings no to
like tight tourniquets or tight braces
or something that might obstruct the
blood flow it's a balance thank you no
that's great and now Gabby I'd love to
hear from your story as well because I
think that's also something that a lot
of people don't realize is pregnancy can
also be a huge Factor when blood clots
are coming into play so I'd love to hear
your story as well yeah so um in
2021 uh after my second child was born I
had a kidney infection I had a fever for
like seven days and then I went to the
hospital and I stayed there for seven
days also and as the doctors were
checking my exams they found a clot in
my pelvic vein is that the right term in
my pelvic vein and uh we were able to
they were able to repair the damage
because it was an early diagnosis so the
damage were were not like as bad as we
expected so um I had no I I almost
didn't have symptoms symptoms yeah but
it was bad like the medication hurts um
and after after that I changed like a
lot of things in my life I started doing
exercises every time I'm in a flight
like a long flight long trip I try to
walk on the plane and I started paying
attention more attention to this little
things that can like prevent for this to
not happen again yeah and I guess for
you too as you know an influencer and
someone who shares like their pretty
much you know everything with the
internet I mean for me I was like do I
share this do I keep this a secret like
what do I do so what was that like for
you kind of deciding to share your
story um I did share my story but not
like with so many details as I'm doing
now and I don't know I I I shared like
after I was discharged cuz I was
comfortable with with this but when I
was in the hospital I didn't post
anything I didn't said anything because
I I didn't know like what was going to
happen like you know
yeah no I did the same I waited until
after I was out then I could process
things and then of course you just had a
baby as well so you've got so many
different things on your mind so what is
this like kind of sharing this with your
family have you kind of made your kids
aware of this like how are you kind of
bringing them up to kind of I guess for
their awareness of blood
clots yeah um my babies they they knew I
was sick but not so sick you know um my
family got really scared um they got
worried but my mom was with me the whole
time she took care of me and she still
does cuz you know when you've been
through this like you're not the same
your life is not the same you're you
live like
scared and you try to do everything to
prevent this to happen again for sure
and I think the thing with the pulmonary
embolism too is my when I also had one
it went to my lungs and I was like I
used to run a lot so I thought oh after
I'm feeling better I'm just going to be
able to go back out there and you really
don't ever feel that same way that you
did before and you always have kind of
that fear and especially because that
day that I got my clot I also had gone
for like a seven mile run and now I'm
like I can't even do that anymore
because it's you just I'm like I have
that fear in the back of my mind like
well if I do that again am I gonna get
another clot but I think H making those
simple changes especially in your health
I think is really important and then
Kelsey for you because you've been I
mean you really don't know what is
causing this I mean how has that been
for you you know changes that you've had
to make in your life and and kind of
friends and family because everyone has
to be aware of this sure so in the
beginning I was a lot more private about
all the
circumstances and situations that were
happening I think because I didn't
understand and because I've done all the
genetic testing and things like even
into my family now and I don't have any
factor and everything's IR remarkable or
normal um other than being the having
the diagnosis of having a blood clot um
that I was more private but just the
changes that happened in my life
especially with I didn't lose my job but
I was on medical leave at a young in my
early 20s for six months at one point
and then figuring out like where is my
career going to go and I was in grad
school that I did then started sharing
more and more and leaning on to my
friends for support and I will say that
they were absolutely incredible but I
did have a few friends that I don't
think this is talked about enough that
didn't understand how could this have
happened but then two months from now
you took a vacation somewhere they
didn't they didn't necessarily think it
was 100% truthful on my end so it was
really hard navigating all of that and
um I think just as it's continued to go
on I've really leaned on my friends and
family for their support I have kind of
just started well now I've started my
own business because I'm like this is
the direction I need to go with myself
but it's changed my life and that it has
taken my passions that I was more just
excited to do out you know like outside
of work and school and it has made me
literally create a career and a
lifestyle out of things that I once
didn't take for granted but I didn't I
didn't know know like one day it could
all be gone and I had that realization
in the hospital thinking man I just
bought a new SUV I'll never forget
laying in the hospital like my car
payments do I just have this new SUV I'm
supposed to be going on a trip I can't
do it like all of that's taken away so I
think experiencing that in my early 20s
has now put me in my early 30s and I
just live my life completely different
um and and taking precautions like we
said I wear compression sleeve I wear
compression socks I actually do not take
a flight that's longer than 5 hours
without taking a day layover and um
taking anti-coagulants and blood blood
thinners every day and not missing a
dose and I will say that my friends are
amazing one time I was walking downtown
Houston the roads are terrible and I
almost tripped and my friend literally
grabbed me and was like you are not
going to hard like fall hard like I'm
not going to let you touch the ground
and hit the ground on blood thinners so
it's just it's it's been a whirlwind a
roller coaster but I will say I am very
grateful to have experienced all of this
I thought it was interesting as soon as
I started on blood thinners I hit my
head all the time for some reason
because I I it was in the back of my
mind of like you can't hit your head
don't run into anything I was running
into everything not hard but like it
still was just like because you become
so hyper aware of it I mean there's so
many things that you you are you can be
afraid to do like even riding a bike
because like if I fall and there's so
many small things that you do have to
make adjustments but I think there's one
thing or a piece of advice that I've
kind of found throughout this whole
journey and then just even like my
journey through like martial arts is is
when you have an injury what else can
you do instead of that that same thing
like if you can't do this like what can
you do to kind of develop yourself
outside of that like okay well if I
sprain my ankle I think I can kind of
still do some push-ups on my on my knees
so it's kind of figuring out ways to
kind of live a new life and it's not
easy and and I think you know talking
with loved ones and even just the
internet I am so glad that I had my
audience because I found so many other
people that had the same exact diagnosis
that I had they were telling me about
their rib removal surgery and they're
like look here's my scars and it was
just people sharing such vulnerable
pieces of of their lives and I think
that's really so special about the
internet and you know Gabby for you did
you kind of have anything similar to
that when when you shared your
story sorry was what was the question
sorry oh when you shared your story did
you have a lot of your audience kind of
share their own personal stories yeah
totally um actually today when I posted
about the live the the the stream that
we we doing um everybody commented like
oh I have someone in my family who
already been through this I I personally
have been through this so hard so I
think everybody know somebody that has
already been through this
and um when once you talk about this uh
you get surprised about how many people
have blood clots
and things like that and nobody really
talks about it at all so it's good for
us to share to people don't feel alone
you
know yeah just I want to jump in because
I think this is very important that
people talk about it and get support
from many different areas but one of the
biggest groups and and sometimes it it's
hard if your family is living in
different places to actually find out
what your family history is right
because if you have relatives who've had
blood clot and your relatives have had
them at a young age you are likely at an
increased risk for having a blood clot
as well and so knowing your family
history going into things may be very
helpful so you know if your father had a
blood clot at age 40 or age 50 um
sometimes depending on how old you are
when they have a clot you may not really
be aware your parents may not want to
tell you if you're 10 or you're 12 and
they they don't really understand you
know well yeah Daddy was in the hospital
but what does that mean and so finding
out and when you get to your 20s and
asking your family sometimes even before
you have a blood clot can be very
important uh family information to know
yeah something else that was kind of
interesting is because um like I have a
very low blood pressure and like heart
rate so when I was in the the ICU my
sister was there and she she we
basically because we're super techsavvy
so like we have all like these tech
gadgets so we know like our heart rate
we know our blood pressure and she was
just looking at the machine and she's
like your blood pressure is rising like
your heart rate's High which for a
normal person it wasn't so like we
called the doctor in and I started
feeling like something weird in my chest
and I was like something doesn't feel
right I feel like my heart rate's
elevated they're like no that looks good
that's normal I go that's normal but
that's not my normal so I think for
anybody who you know just take your
blood pressure go into the pharmacy one
day just put your arm in that sleeve
every once in a while and just kind of
know your base because I think that's
super helpful especially for doctors
because they don't have that history of
information do you have anything to add
to that Gene that we should be kind of
looking for yeah no I I I think you know
knowing your own Baseline heart rate and
knowing that you know we may not think
90 is or 100 is really high for most
people but if your Baseline is 50 that's
that's twice right and so I think the
other thing that I think you um Justine
or maybe it was Kelsey or even Gabby or
all three of you mentioned is that this
feeling of anxiety right with pulmonary
embolis like you're not quite sure
what's going on and your heart is your
heart rate is usually higher with a
pulmonary embolis and it's kind of hard
to tell where that's coming from so
don't ignore those kinds of symptoms um
you know definitely if you've had a
pulmonary imis or even a DBT or any type
of blood clot in the past I always tell
my patients do not be afraid to go to
the emergency department and say I've
had a blood clot and I'm worried I have
one no one will say you're like you
shouldn't be here you're crying wolf
they should really check you out um to
make sure that you don't have a blood
cloth now I mean Kelsey we heard some of
your symptoms I mean Gab did you have
any symptoms you said you didn't really
have any but they still found it
anyway yeah I I I didn't have symptoms
at all like I had a fever that was the
only symptom and I think it was a
miracle that I went to the hospital
because I thought it was like a throat
infection or something like that but the
fever kept like for seven days so I
thought I think it's time to go to the
hospital cuz i' I've been taking medic
medications for the fever and nothing's
working okay let's go to the hospital
and as I I went to the hospital
and it was a coincidence that they found
the clock in in the puges sorry so um I
think it was a miracle because I didn't
had symptoms at all you know I mean you
still had that fever which thankfully
you were able to kind of know that
that's not normal and how much how long
after was this when you had your your
first or your
pregnancy um it was my second PR
pregnancy my baby had like um three
three months four months almost four
month so and Jean I guess I mean I I
don't have any children and I'm not
familiar with you know how all of that
works as far as like cloths and
pregnancy can you explain to us kind of
how that works and is that kind of a
normal thing to happen does it happen
right after pregnancy three months like
what's what is the usual kind of thing
that people should look for I know these
are very very good questions um as I
sort of alluded to before both estrogen
containing uh oral contraceptives and
pregnancy um when women are have either
one of those going on um they're very
very high risk for getting a clot
because the estrogen levels um increase
the proclotting factors and they
decrease the natural anti clotting
factors and and we do a lot of hand
waving about out thinking that that may
be you know historically important and
allowed people to survive childbirth
because you're in a more proclotting
State and that state you know continues
through pregnancy and at least the first
six weeks after delivery although some
people would argue up to 12 weeks or
three months later your hormones are are
fluctuating and it's basically pregnancy
is a hypercoagulable state it is even
potentially um a stronger State than say
if you have heterozygous or one copy of
the factor five lien gene mutation which
is an inherited blood clotting Disorder
so it can be very um people need to look
out uh during pregnancy after pregnancy
for about three months uh at least six
to months uh six weeks um and if they're
taking birth control pills and and I
think that I I want to stress you know
for for like women in their young 20s
not to ignore symptomss of DVT PE uh
because we do see that that patients
develop these uh unexpectedly on on
these uh contraceptives but Gabby um it
sounds like you were sick right you had
a kidney infection you had a fever you
had a throat infection infection can can
be a source of blood clots people who
get admitted to the hospital are at risk
for getting blood clots so if you put in
what we call the postpartum State your
Post delivery you've got an infection
you've got a fever you're in the
hospital lying in bed I don't want to
say it's a no-brainer because my kids
tell me that that phrase is out but um
you know all those things add up to to
make it easier for you to get a blood
club I'm also uh reading in the chat as
well so I think that there's so many
other people that are sharing their
stories so thank you guys so much for
sharing those um we do have a question
here that says is there an age when
women should stop taking birth control
pills that's an excellent question
um and and so there are data that
definitely show so first of all the risk
of getting a blood clot just increases
with age and it really takes off at age
60 so that's why if your grandmother had
a blood clot at age 80 we're less
worried than if your uncle had a blood
clot at age 40 um there are data from
that are on the CDC the Center for
Disease Control website about the risks
with age certainly if if you the risk We
Believe goes up after age
35 um and if you smoke that risk is
significantly increased uh but when
women start to get over 40 and 45 we
suggest if they need some sort of
hormonal treatment they use other
formulations than the estrogen
progesterone birth control
pills yeah I feel like this is something
that no one has ever taught you know you
would have no idea especially at a young
age like oh birth okay I'm going to take
that because I don't want to get
pregnant but then there's so many other
side effects and I think there's so many
side effects for all sorts of types of
you know medications so you really do
have to look into that because it's not
it's a side effect for a reason um
something else that I'm curious about
with with all of you ladies is how was
your mental health kind of afterwards
because I know I was just a wreck like
not only did I feel like I was never
going to be able to do any of my
favorite activities again I thought like
I can't I I basically just felt like
like I was I was like a prisoner now
like I couldn't do anything and I mean
this is now like a year and a half later
I'm doing all my favorite things I'm
running again got back to Jiu-Jitsu so
you know it takes a lot of time and I
think a lot of patience with yourself so
um Kelsey like how have you been dealing
because obviously this is something that
you're still dealing with and I would
love to hear kind of like your coping
mechanisms because I also feel like this
is incredible you you've started a
business so you've kind of created you
know this this this lemonade out of out
of the lemons
yeah um I'm gen like generally a very
happy non-anxious person I thank God for
that um so I would say overall in life
my mental health I feel like I'm
thriving and I do have a very strong
healthy mental health however I could
see how if I allowed myself to worry
about these blood clots that I've had
and potentially having blood clots it
could be a really scary downward
slippery slope specifically and I don't
think this is talked about enough the
finances that come with being ill um and
going to the hospital or just even going
to the ER because you're scared that it
might be
something that's that's probably one of
the most triggering things for me is
thinking how much money I've spent and
how much money I still owe and how much
money I'm probably going to owe in the
future um and also thinking my mental
health around child planning I always
used to say I don't think I would ever
want to have a kid but that was before
meeting my significant other and falling
in love and now I want to have a baby
and I would love to be a mother but I'm
SC I'm I'm terrified to be honest and my
hematologist and my PCP they have now
since retired they're amazing people but
they've been with me from the beginning
you know
so um my coping me mechanisms are really
just to I believe in God and I lean on
to him and put Faith in everything into
him and I think to myself if I was
supposed to be dead in God by now I
would be so I'm supposed to be here
fulfilling my mission now and and just
trying to put as much positivity as I
can in the world but I I'm not
invincible and I can say that there have
been times where I'm like Oh my goodness
this is going to be so expensive or I
felt like I could have a house by now or
I could have this but I had to put my
money somewhere else you know so I um my
M my mom is a mental health therapist
and I advocate for therapy I think that
you should be in therapy before you need
therapy and I always tell people I
recommend that um it's not just for
broken people or people that don't know
where to turn and um I think talking to
people that you trust and in my faith is
what has helped me through all of this
that's amazing no and I think you've
gone through so much so just to be able
to hear how you've come out on the other
side I think it's such an inspirational
story for so many other people who are
struggling with this especially if you
know you're fresh off the clot like it's
it really is traumatic because it
doesn't seem like you you have the
information and that's why I think you
know just being a part of and finding
the world thrombosis organization was so
incredible because they have so many
resources for people whether you know
this is your first clot your second and
and you're dealing with that it's just
been really amazing um and so Gabby for
you I mean how has that been kind of you
know dealing with not only the clot but
also your family and trying to like keep
your cool and keep everyone
together yeah um by the time I had the
plot um it was really bad for my mental
health but after that I think it was
really important for me because it made
me my more responsible with my health
with my body with everything especially
cuz I have three kids so I'm not alone
they depend on me and I think therapy as
you said is really really really
important like I've been on therapy
since then since I had the clot and it's
really important for
me and that's
it yeah Jean do you have any other
recommendations for people who you know
may be struggling with where do you even
look or go to for help because I feel
like a lot of people just might feel
stuck like what do we do now yeah no and
this is great and it's great to hear and
and watch actually the three of you
discuss what's very common in people
who've had blood clots I I some some
patients you know describe it as PTSD
right they get shorter breath and oh my
gosh all the the you know being in the
Intensive Care Unit or being in the
hospital or Gabby it sounds like you did
the injection type of anti-coagulants
like an oxop parin or or some sort of
low molecular heprin so and I do tell
patients that doctors and nurses and
nurse practitioners and physician
assistants don't know what you're
thinking so you need to let people know
because they can provide you with
resources but sometimes traditional
medicine we're we're so busy dayto day
that that we're not the best at at
pushing out those resources and so don't
be afraid to look um either to speak to
friends but social media someone said
has become a great way to spread
information both usually upfront and and
honest and and correct and sometimes you
got to take some of it with a grain of
salt there are known societies um out
there that are advocacy groups for
patients who've had blood clots um and
you can find these resources on the
world thrombosis day website many of
these um uh forums and Foundations and
societ ladies hold webinars they hold
support groups they have once a week you
know just like we're doing now by
Facebook um group uh support sessions
not necessarily Bonafide therapy or
oneon-one but it's a a way to share
information um and deal with the stress
and deal with strategies for you know
situations in the future so I encourage
everybody to look for those um and um uh
you know be on the lookout and and share
you know sharing your stories like you
are now opens many people's eyes to the
fact that thrombosis exists and and
that's a great
start yeah I mean for me definitely like
relying on my audience you know they've
I feel like you know I post content all
the time it's super happy and then for
them to see sort of this traumatic thing
happen but like they I know a lot of
them are watching right now so like I
could not be more appreciative of how
many people shared their stories because
that's hard you know it's hard to share
but then they're I mean I am still a
stranger and they're sharing that with
me and the ways that they were able to
cope has been so helpful so thank you to
everyone watching and thank you to
everyone who has shared your story like
we definitely really appreciate that um
I guess again for uh Gabby and Kelsey
whoever wants to answer if you guys both
want to answer I mean for you guys now
kind of going forward is there any kind
of support or any message that you want
to give out to people to kind of just
let them know like hey it's okay you
need to if you need to get checked out
like this is this is what you should
do sure so I remember being in the
hospital and
thinking I'll be back at work in two
weeks or something and hearing the The
Physician say we don't think you're
going to be back because my my portal
van thrombosis caused a lot of issues
down the road with my pancreas and my
gallbladder had to be removed and a lot
of GI issues followed after that and I
remember them saying yeah we're thinking
minimum six months and my mind was like
six months my world is g to end like no
and I mean it's been six years now right
like the time went like this so I
encourage everyone especially people
that feel like you need to go to work
and you have to support your family and
you can't be taking off to go to
physician
appointments do it because what you do
now to make sure that you are changing
your life to to get better will Pro
protect you and make it that much easier
and potentially heal you of all of your
ailments that could have be worse if you
put it off go to the doctor and another
thing about it is if you're scared I
know there's been so many times where
I'm like Mom I I cannot go get that CT
scan I'm too scared what if something
comes up I don't want to go get those
ultrasounds do it because early
detection is so important
and it is literally key
to I
believe the outcome that you want in the
end of just being free of the diagnosis
and I don't want other people that are
in our shoes to worry about all the
things that don't matter because at the
end of the day your health and your
happiness matters and without either
what's the point so that's something
that I really preach into people even if
my my friends um son he broke his leg
and I'm like you better go to that
physical therapy because you don't want
him to step down a curb in 10 years and
break your leg like so that's my my best
piece of advice to everyone don't let
the time and the doctor's appointments
deter you and the fear it's funny you
mentioned the the time frame because
they did the same thing they're like
okay we're going to have you on blood
thinners for at least six months and
then we'll reassess and I was like wait
a minute that's a really long time and
at the time I also had a vacation plan
the next week and I remember coming out
of the operating room the first time and
I was like I've got all these random
videos that my sister filmed which I'm
glad she did because they're kind of
funny looking back now but at the time
not funny and I was just on you know
coming out of the the um out of the
drugs and and I was like do you think
I'm gonna be able to go to Hawaii in two
days and they're like sure yeah so I
took that video and I was like remember
when you said I could go to Hawaii in a
couple days he's like I didn't think you
were GNA actually bring back the proof
he's like no you can not fly um which is
kind of interesting because I think a
lot of people don't realize you know
flying also can be a source of of a lot
of blood clots because you're at
different you know elevation um Gan I
want to talk to you about that before I
would like to get some advice from um
from Gabby do you have any advice for
people who may be going through
something similar or if they have any
symptoms yeah um I think um do your
checkups like often don't be scared to
find something cuz as she said early
diagnosis can save your life and may
like make like the the
damaging low you
know definitely for sure yeah the the
early detection yeah pay attention to
your body because it speaks to us so
this the symptoms are quiet but they are
there so pay
attention for sure yeah so I I I also
travel a lot and I mean Gan like what
should we be doing obviously the
compression socks um but there are other
things too um that people might not
cancer treatments can also be a huge
source of potential blood clots so I
guess I've got so many questions for you
okay so we need some some travel tips
and then also what are some other things
that can cause clots that might not be
as common that we think yeah no and and
before we even get started on that I
want to Echo do not be afraid to go to
your medical care team we will write you
a letter that say says you were there
and and hopefully that will excuse your
your managers and your work from from
having any repercussions on you for
taking care of yourself um so so flying
in you know we all see there are not a
lot of great studies looking at people
who fly right because millions of people
fly but not everyone gets a blood clot
and and so there are factors that
increase your Rich risk and we've talked
about the length of travel but I've seen
people get blood clots with flights for
three or four hours so again you have to
have your own individual risk factors
getting up and walking around every hour
wearing compression stockings absolutely
one thing that I find even in my own
field like so I'm a very subub
specialist in hematology that does
coagulation and thrombosis and not every
hematologist does this not every
cardiologist is up on this if you've had
a blood clot before and you are not on
anti-coagulation on all the time one of
the things that I do though is give
people anti-coagulation before they you
know that for them to take before they
get on the plane so discuss that with
your doctor there are not a lot of data
but those of us who really do coag know
that this works I'm trying to spread
that information uh on the medical side
um and then you know lots of different
disorders so as Justine mentioned cancer
itself increases your risk for getting a
clot just by having the cancer and some
cancers are more prothrombotic or more
hypercoaguable Cancer Treatments can do
this um being significantly overweight
increases your risk of getting a clot
just like having a heterozygous protham
and gene mutation so hopefully that will
encourage people to to maintain their
work weight and work to get at a a
reasonable uh weight you know a body
mass index of 30 or below um other
factors are medical illnesses we see
people who have flares of inflammatory
bowel disease rheumatoid arthritis lupus
other types of disorders like that when
they're active um can cause blood clots
as well so be aware of your own family
risks I think that helps don't be afraid
to bring it up with your pH physician no
matter what is going on say Hey you know
my you know father had a blood clot at
40 and his BR his sister had a blood
clot because all of that important
information
for your your care your medical care
team to
know so now going forward I think we're
all kind of in our healing phase and
we're all aware of blood cloths at this
point so I guess is there anything that
you guys are now doing differently than
you used to um are you like Super Hyper
aware like what what has changed kind of
in your day-to-day Gabby if you want to
go
first so I think um the main change that
the clot made in me it was in my head
cuz I I didn't like go to the doctor to
do checkups or think like that I was not
responsible at all with my health with
my um food with exercises some things
that made difference make difference and
now I pay attention to every detail to
everything that can make the situation
worse if there is something happening in
my mouth
in my body so I started to pay more
attention and I think that's the main
difference that that I
had and Kelsey what about
you I I Echo that as well I mean I never
had to go to the doctor when I was
younger um I never was sick until I got
sick really um but I would say for me
probably maybe it's different an answer
because it's been the ongoing for me and
it keeps appearing but if things don't
make me happy or like genuinely bring me
joy in my life or relationships don't I
don't have time for it anymore I I also
um my background is in healthc care and
I've seen people come and go and I've
seen the other side of people not
surviving and I think you know I just
the importance of how beautiful and
delicate life is if it doesn't serve me
a purpose then it might be a great
purpose for someone else but it's just
not for me and that's what um I would
say constantly having these scares has
really taught me and it's given me a a
an outlook on life to where I just
despite the craziness I'm just happy and
I don't know if I would have that had I
not experienced all of this
that's a really incredible Outlook and I
think that's super helpful for a lot of
people because you know when you do
first get this you are sort of in this
state of confusion and just hearing that
you know you're still going through this
and having such an amazing positive
outlook I think is super helpful and it
is really it's it's it's scary and
especially I think because it
essentially is sort of this invisible
disease where you would look at us and
we're like oh you guys are all perfectly
fine so it's hard for people to think
that there's something wrong with you
and you know getting people to believe
that like you um Kelsey were talking
about like taking off work and then
going on a trip and they're like wait I
thought you were you were sick you're
like well yes but I think the education
process is very important um and I guess
going back to that too the medical bills
because that it is very expensive I mean
ending up in the ICU for days and all of
that care that you need um I guess Jean
for you I mean what is your best
suggestion for for people like you know
making sure you have have health
insurance but what if you don't have
health insurance like what should we be
doing yeah no so so this comes up um
because I I I you know never talk
politics but the Affordable Care Act has
made it easier for people to get
insurance um I have family members who
own their own business and sometimes
have gaps in their medical coverage
right um and yet then something happens
and they need to see someone um you
should get the medical care you need and
you should not be afraid to go and let
that keep you no matter what your
insurance status is no matter what your
status is in the United States with
regard to citizenship and everything
else go to the emergency room get
treated um if you are concerned about
symptoms uh that are typical or not
typical of as we've discussed in the
last
hour they may make you pay but you know
you can pay $10 a month you can pay $5 a
month it may take you a long time but
it's important to get the care and the
financial side of the hospital is
willing to work out many deals based on
what you can afford and lots of other
things I could go into there a lot of
hospitals that are considered safety
nets and they treat people for free so
do not let any Financial issue stand in
the way of of getting care what I do
tell my patients though when they get
bills do not pay on the spot okay wait
for those insurance companies to haggle
it all out let the hospital hag it all
out with the insurance company and then
alter and that can take months so do not
be dismayed when you see these large
medical bills showing up and that you
have to pay immediately everything and
sell your car and get rid of your house
do not do that you can tell it's a
little strong opinion of mine but but
that's advice I give my patients all
right do not be dismayed call the
financial office at the hospital where
or wherever you were cared for do not
give it all up and let those if you have
insurance let them haggle it out if you
don't there are still mechanisms where
you no one's going to make you
destitute thank you so much I think that
was super helpful because I mean we're
sitting there in the hospital and my
sister was just like how much do you
think this is all gonna cost I was like
I'm not right now can we just wait later
and you know when you do get those bills
it is absolutely shocking and you know
I'm not sure what the healthcare is in
Brazil it may be a little bit different
so I guess it's it's definitely very
different here in the US so what is that
like for you um Gabby in Brazil so I
have health insurance um I have a a good
financial
situation I don't know how to say that
in English but here in Brazil we have
like public Hospital those um for free
so I think for the people here it's like
easier you know to find the the
diagnosis and take care of of your
health I I would like to add that
speaking of the financial peace and
insurance I just recently as of this
year have finally branched out because I
got the confidence to start my own
business and the biggest piece of that
was I'm not going to have health
insurance
that's what was like I can't do this and
so what I did is I called people that I
know in my town that I lived and I said
does anyone have a job for me that I can
do to have health insurance and it's
hilarious my mom and I laugh about this
all the time I am the attendance lady at
a junior high by day and at night time
I'm doing my own business but you know
what I have health insurance so I don't
want people to be
discouraged by thinking oh I can't do
this because I can't follow my dreams
because I'm in to need health insurance
there's a way and you can do it and it
might be funny and it's crazy that my
life has ended up here but I'm still
doing what I love and I made it happen
and I don't want people to be
discouraged thinking that you like this
is the only way there's always a way if
it's meant to be and I just really
believe that from the bottom of my heart
that's such incredible advice and I'm
just so appreciative that you guys are
all here we only have a few more minutes
left so I guess I'll just go around and
you guys can share any last words of
encouragement or anything that you feel
like sharing um Jean we can start with
you yeah no again I think this is
excellent I think um people should feel
free to share their stories and by the
three of you Justine and Kelsey and
Gabby sharing your stories just opens up
people's eyes to the fact that blood
clots exist and that they occur in young
otherwise very healthy people uh and I
think you know to um for people who are
uh watching this uh live uh World
thrombosis day.org is our website uh for
World thrombosis day um there is a lot
of information on there if you have
friends or family members who've had a
clot definitely share that information
with them there are a lot of support
groups out there but also be aware of
the risks and your own family history
the S the risks and the signs of blood
clots um so that if you think you have
one uh you know what the signs are the
and you go get prompt medical attention
so thank you for having me tonight thank
you so much and then Gabby do you have
any last words for anyone or anything
else you'd like to
share so um the message that I want to
share is like take care of your body
because you know you see on the internet
you hear stories about diagnosis and you
never think it's going to happen to you
till the day it does so
um take care of your health
um don't be afraid to go to the hospital
even if it's nothing you have to know if
it it is nothing it is really nothing so
don't be afraid and everything will be
okay
anyway thank you so much and then Kelsey
you've shared so much already with us
but I would love to hear some last
parting words from you sure well first
thank you all for being on here with me
and in just welcoming us to your channel
um just everyone on the panel um and I
really want to take in W thros to stay
but I really want to take this time
to say two things one is all of the time
I get when I go to the emergency room
you don't look that sick to have XYZ and
it's so frustrating because I'm like
okay but I am this is the diagnosis so I
just want healthc care providers that
are listening
to maybe not use that language because
you don't know what someone's really
going through until you get the results
to say like oh you don't look that sick
like well now I got to go to the ICU so
that's something that I would like to
educate Health Care Providers on and
then also Ed um just to advocate for
yourself like everyone has said to know
your Baseline um it definitely makes a
big difference in the end and taking the
opportunity just to say thank you to all
of the healthc Care providers that have
been on my team that have now retired or
that are still on my team if you're
listening I sent you the link I hope you
are I couldn't be here without you thank
you to my friends thank you to everyone
who has supported me and I hope that if
anyone needs any acts of uh words of
encouragement prayer just to speak about
anything that has to do with world
thrombos to stay or blood clots my door
is always open and I am here to help and
be an advocate or just a voice for
anyone that needs it
oh my gosh thank you guys so much this
was so much fun and thank you to
everyone in the chat we have been
reading all of your super inspirational
stories and again this entire stream was
in honor of the 10th anniversary of the
world thrombosis day and you guys can
check out more information at World
thrombosis day.org and you guys can get
involved in the campaign share this with
your friends share this with your
families because you really never know
when this might affect you or someone
you know and just this small piece of
information could save a life yours your
friends your family you never know so
feel free to share it take a look at the
website and just kind of get informed
because I think that's the most
important part is just having this in
the back of your mind if you ever have
any of these symptoms or if you ever
spot these symptoms with a friend or
family you really could save their lives
so thank you again Jean Gabby and Kelsey
you guys were so incredible and thank
you to everyone for watching and happy
world thrombosis day bye everyone by
thank you guys so so much thank
you